I mean didn't Google just announced last
week some clip-on camera that captures
what's in front of you in typical Google
form they pitched it though it's like
this is the center of our AI learning
platform about the world which is the
same marketing mistake they made with
everyone wants a face computer now
everyone is computer everyone does not
want an AR learning camera clipped to
their chest but they probably do
actually want a camera mmm I think from
really a creative perspective I think
that the struggle for interestingness
that's a line that we see is allowing we
were pitching but like solving the
struggle for interestingness from a
video perspective is paramount to having
anything succeed and I think what
snapchat did that was so amazing
beyond the story mechanism being so
fascinated but like I dismissed lenses
is kind of a gimmick when it first came
out but what lenses did was it solved
the struggle for interesting this from
both the creators perspective and the
viewers perspective here put dog ears on
that's amore that's interesting that's
fun and I think the trouble that we're
seeing certainly we saw at beam that
they're seeing with spectacles and that
I think every single live platform none
of which have truly succeeded yet is
because they don't address that struggle
for interestingness and I think that the
reason why video games have succeeded in
the live space is because they do here's
something that we all understand it's a
game and I get to see your face playing
it there's that's that's dealing with
the struggle for interestingness but I
think broadly live is too wide open it's
too there is no box there and I think
what we were trying to do with beam like
so one of the things we talked about
should be a four-second sic clip or six
second clip so if you string a bunch of
them together it needs to feel fun like
you're watching an edited movie we were
wrong it got boring quickly watching
people's raw lives got boring quickly so
how are you going to deal with that in
the future if you're handling multiple
feeds from all over the world so with
the product so we learned a lot with
beam v1 that we imported to a much much
smaller problem set which is what we're
dealing with in panels the product
that's out now and panels is just it's
purely about opinion it's what is your
opinion on these five stories today
these things happening in the world
we wanted to be this place where you get
to actually see the full spectrum of
perspectives on a on an issue that might
be controversial that might be you know
what do you think about the Republican
healthcare proposal to actually see you
at a civil debate in video looks like on
that and what we having the the reason
the way we made it more interesting it's
like it's just really contained so I
think we took a lot of the little
product cues about how to set some up
one up in in context both to create and
consume in which they're gonna be
articulate and pointed and fast let me
do that some priming and there's just
there's some ways that we actually try
and guide you towards creating something
that's really compelling but the domain
is much much smaller like we're not
trying to make this that's not the
platform for everything you could
possibly take a video of in the world it
is what do you think about this a story
yeah it's it's it's if you had so many
cameras I say something interesting
there you have no idea what to say if
you hand someone a camera and say you
know what do you think about the latest
health care proposal they might know
probably something to say and that
something will be tied to a specific
narrative so that is an attempt at
addressing that struggle for
interestingness right I mean it's tricky
because it seems that the internet
deviates towards like kind of a [ __ ]
show most of the time people aren't
you've turned off YouTube comments I see
that you still have them but I'm mature
enough YouTube comments yeah better you
still get views yeah not as many as you
yeah you'll get an island in the
algorithm for took for that they punish
you severely for that oh really yeah
maybe we should turn them back on but I
agree comments are absolutely toxic if
you go into your community settings on
the left hand side you can go down you
can highlight words and if any of those
words pop up those comments will be
automatically hidden oh all right so if
you were to go into my library of those
words you would find the most disgusting
dictionary bibliography of words that
humans have ever ever uttered and the
funny thing about that is people who use
the kind of slurs and profanities that I
have blocked they also don't have to
spell those slurs or profanities so you
have to come up with every spelling of
every derogatory word you could ever
ident
because they don't know how to spell
well but yeah I mean here's the thing
about that that I think it's really easy
and I especially think for people our
age who sort of grew up on the very
early internet which was a very very
small place compared to the almost half
the world that has access to it now
there's this easy thing to go like oh
it's just the Internet it's a gross
place like anyone can say anything I
actually think we as people who make
products need to stop thinking like that
and start thinking about now the entire
world now has access to this thing how
do we actually design it purposefully so
that that doesn't happen how do you
actually create a place for people to
not be harassed to actually have a civil
discourse if you're designing a social
product and you kind of just throw your
hands up and go it's the Internet
you're wrong like that is not that is
not the era we live in and we need to
take on that responsibility as people
who make these things who just said
somebody smart just said I used to go to
the Internet to escape the real world
and now I go to the real world to escape
the Internet oh yeah I don't know who
that was
that's how tweet was floating around but
I think that that pretty much sums it up
and so is it just like heavily community
moderated like how do you guys cuz this
is like obviously a contentious opinion
how do you put these ideas into your
product yeah I mean it's there's no one
answer and I don't think we are not
gonna come and say like here's exactly
what we're doing it is perfect what
we're doing right now with panels is
we're very purposefully building it
slowly it's not an open community yet
you have to sign up give a some info
about yourself and we're trying to let
people in in real demographic balance
we're trying to you know in general tech
early adopters tends to skew a little
bit Mayo we're trying to make sure that
that doesn't skew the community and so
we actually set up a place where when we
do open the doors fully it is something
where you're like oh all kinds of
opinions are welcomed here mmm
trolling doesn't work and isn't going to
get me attention so moderation is
definitely a piece of that but it's
every aspect of the product design and
every aspect is how you build the
community which I don't think I don't
think at this point you can just have
okay we'll just let everyone on and
free-for-all and will moderate out the
bad stuff
you'd be thinking a lot more carefully
yeah and you're also building like a
media plus product company I mean
they're kind of wrapped together do you
see the world shifting towards that you
know like controlling your content and
making lots of content that people like
while also building product yeah I mean
I think that almost every media company
right now they're their technology
products are just a device to further
disseminate the media that they're
making
there isn't a holistic consideration of
how can the media and then the
technology they're using to promote that
media how can they have a more symbiotic
relationship and I think that's easy to
talk about that problem it's very hard
to talk about solutions and I think
panel being panels is a very literal
version of integrating those two it's a
very good example but I can tell you
plainly that it's it's very hard to
realize like the way we've integrated
being thus far into our content I think
so boring
I don't think it's that interesting I
think it's much more interesting to
explain it like we have this
crowdsourcing product that we can have
people chiming in from around the world
and instead of having panelists that are
old bearded men we have panelist from
all around the world if that's
fascinating that's a very compelling
idea but then when you see the reality
of it you're like I don't care so these
are very challenging problems to solve
and I think again the benefit that we
have here is that we are trying to solve
them from from day one we're trying to
solve them proactively instead of
reactively we're not going to be backing
our successful big media company into
solving these problems we're building a
company around those problems hmm and is
managing these like disparate kinds of
teams new and weird for you or have you
felt like you figured it out so far no I
mean I absolutely it is new and weird
you know I think I've I've always been
on the other sort of the other
arrangement where we have like we have
Technology team where people or I work
on a technology product or in a team
that makes technology product that lots
of media gets made with never having
both of those end of the same roof so I
every single day it's on that very basic
thing that I was talking about it
getting people in the newsroom to
realize that this can change that we are
in 100% control of the product we're
using that's I mean that requires like
daily reminders rejiggering of the way
that we work figuring out all right how
do we actually get a producer who sits
not just on the news team but also with
the product team and actually you know
gathers feedback brings it into the
actual product the perspective of hey I
have to make a video and it's due
tomorrow and I would love to include
people from panels but like these 10
things don't work right so ya know it is
very it's very different I think it's
fairly uncharted I don't think there are
many people who have tried to do both
simultaneously like this my response to
that question is that that does a great
job so kind of transitioning but
something that I also think is really
cool about you guys is a just like
overall creative output like when you
started vlogging cuz I've known Matt for
a while but like he started talking
about you to me and he's like oh yeah
man he's doing videos every day and like
having made some videos myself I was
like holy [ __ ] this is a lot of work and
this is a lot of editing and one of the
common questions throughout all the the
Twitter responses to us was about like
creative process in creative energy and
do you guys have any like rituals or
practices to just consistently put out
creative work both on the engineering
side and videos
I mean on the video side that's
something I can speak to very well the
the ritualistic aspect of what I do is
entirely wrapped in kind of my own like
self-reliance and one thing that's made
abundantly clear to me as I'm working
with this big unbelievably talented
skillful media team here at beam is that
I like I'm a very effective person when
I'm by my
self and when after working groups like
I fall to pieces like does not work well
with others is what it said in every
report card I got until I dropped out of
high school in the 10th grade and I
think that's that's very true so for me
that creative process is one where and
finding that cadence that you talked
about of making a video every day was
one where I removed every obstruction
between me and finishing it and other
people are the biggest obstructions I
have an idea well let's talk through
that idea and the metaphor that I use of
discussing ideas in groups is like when
an idea at its inception it's an ice
cube and it's rock-hard you can look at
it you can see it and you can study and
you know what it is but when a
discussion begins you have to pass that
ice cube around the room it starts to
melt and melt and no and after enough
discussions the ice cubes gone and
everybody's hands are wet and nobody
quite remembers what that idea was
that's a major obstruction so for me
when it comes to creation like remove
that obstruction don't talk don't
involve other people don't need anything
from anyone to realize this new video
every 24 hours and that's that's wildly
effective it doesn't scale period it
seems to crush you to just like actual
time and energy I mean no not me I feel
great about that it's like that that's
like an energy source for me it's the
same thing it's like running the
country's so tired you run a dozen miles
a day it's like no I'm not tired because
I run a dozen miles a day like no I'm
not crushed because I made my video like
the days are done down our days that I
don't I don't finish anything and there
is that sort of dopamine rush you get
when you finish something and there's no
greater sort of punctuation to finishing
something then clicking upload and
sending it out to millions of people so
no like that that's a power source for
me
what's crushing is like now we're trying
to scale that and there's one thing I'm
hyper aware of it's my own limitations
creatively editorially I have a lot of
them and the people we have here working
on our media department especially in
the editorial side are all way more
skilled than I could ever be as far as a
journalist goes incredibly smart
articulate capable amazing on camera
that
looking people than like I could ever so
then how do I sort of impart my
understanding that I've gotten via you
know eight million subscribers and eight
hundred videos how do I share that
understanding and scale at least some
part of that with this incredibly
escaped capable team and I think the
answer to that is something that we've
been working towards for the last year
mm-hmm and what about you Matt I mean
I'll talk about engineering and like
coding building a product because I
think at this point I'm this point my
career manager and like that's very
different it is a very different
skillset and it's something that that
you need to work on a different way but
like I don't think that's quite as
interesting probably to the the early
stage founder as that like I'm the
technical half of the team and holy [ __ ]
we have to we have to you know have this
thing ready for an Apple Keynote and
what am I gonna do right so that's the
that's the context I would give this
advice in and I'd to me like we know
when when that was me
when I was sitting there going like oh
yeah this Apple presentation and I have
to hot glue this app together so we can
show it to them so they'll get excited
and maybe maybe include us in this
keynote the thing that I always try to
pay attention to is just listening to my
own body and head and this is something
that I think all of the not all but a
lot of the startup rhetoric will push
you away from and you say like you know
crush it drink a monster energy drink
stay up all night deliver it and there
is you know once a year max where that's
actually effective and that's the right
thing to do most of the time if you sit
down and the codes not coming it's just
you're struggling you shouldn't be doing
like step away go for a walk come back
and half an hour try again mmm go do
something else that's mindless gets your
head off of it but programming is like a
deeply draining incredibly mentally
complex task and doing it 12 14 hours a
day you're not getting twelve or
fourteen hours of work
and you're just completely fooling
yourself so actually listen to what your
head is telling you you know like
alright I'm not I'm not doing this 100%
right now take 15 minute
and what's your equivalent to Casey's
running my equivalent de Casey's running
is I am so unlike Casey I need like I
need seven hours of sleep and I need to
exercise four days a week and like those
are that's basic basic basic context for
being a functional human for me I'm in
too many years to get to that point
where I'm like that's what I invented
that's why I'm not functional in the
weeks and I'm not functional but it just
like that is baseline that needs to
happen or nothing yeah what else can we
want to talk to early-stage founders
sure yeah that's why I want to talk to
you right now okay well I mean they're
broad there are plenty of broad
questions around like advice right first
yeah company let's let's do advice
supported by funny anecdotes do I'm
gonna start with the funny I've got a
great one I got a great like a tight
five-minute bit right now it's way less
than five minutes when Matt and I were
first pitching the very first iteration
of beam which is like Matt totaled it
and it was mostly just duct tape and
spit it was it was glued together it was
a framer demo that we were pretending
wasn't it yeah it was it was we you know
as a series of what do you call like a
an email feet or something like a series
of cells I guess and you would press on
a cell and a video would start playing
we figured out that when we would hand
it to someone who would be an investor
after they'd scroll up and scroll down
their finger would typically be over the
sixth cell so therefore under the sixth
cell under each cell we had videos that
we meant to feel live but were actually
pre recorded and edited and manipulated
and put in there under that six cell was
a Google class video of Jack who worked
this at the time being pulled over by a
police officer and the interaction of
him talking his way out of a ticket it's
like bright lights ready blue like
nothing more interesting yeah so when we
hand it to an investor they would come
through and invariably hold down on that
like whoa what's happening here and Matt
and I would have this dog-and-pony sure
we leaned over the table I'm like oh my
god oh that's Jack the police
hey Mike yeah the crazy stuff that pops
up in this feed and like that that was
like that was the kind of the kind of
theatrics that we would put on it to me
it's reminiscent of like the stories of
Steve Jobs his first demo for the iPhone
where if he didn't follow this specific
path through the product demo the entire
OS would collapse and that was that was
some of the dog and pony show that we
didn't first first sharing what the app
was capable of or what our hopes for
what
yeah we're well then you also have like
dog and pony show before CNN right we
should talk about the acquisition true
and I think it's the same I think the
thing that that you especially if you're
an engineer and you're approaching these
things you're like you don't think about
all of these interactions our sales
processes like every single time you
talk to someone external whether it's a
potential investor you are selling and I
think it's really hard for engineers to
get that mine six they're like you know
if I if I if I make a good thing it's
just gonna it will sell itself or my
co-founder will sell it it is every
single interaction your solid running
fundraising process running an
acquisition process mechanically and
what it's like in the room they're a
little bit different but essentially
it's the same thing you're you're
selling and selling isn't just
performing and it's not acting a certain
way it is getting as much information as
possible about the other party what they
want how they think what motivates them
what's gonna make them feel like they're
gonna miss out if they don't do
something with you and that's exactly
the same for fundraising as it is for
the acquisition process and we've both
we we played games we figured out ways
to create psychology in the people we
were trying to sell where they really
really thought they had to work with us
and this is an opportunity in a window
that's gonna close it's it's Robert
McNamara's rules of war it's like
empathize with your enemy and in our
case it was always for me the
psychological approach was always sort
of empathizing
either the people we were asking for
money from we're raising or potential
suitors when it was you know acquisition
time but I think that was something that
was really really effective and honestly
like this sounds naive or almost a bit
of a platitude but it's like once I
realized what demonstrating the passion
behind what we were doing the
effectiveness of that you know I lean on
that really really hard for the first
phase of fundraising because of my own
insecurities about my lack of technical
understanding and to quantify my lack of
technical understanding I have zero zero
technical understanding that has to help
me set up my email accounts I I was
really insecure about that and I used to
look to man and it was only through the
process that I realized that any any
investors any understanding realizes
that a good you know a good founder will
hire the best engineers engineers that
are better than then he or she is and
they really don't give a [ __ ] about how
well you can write code they care if you
will succeed or if you will not succeed
and Gary Vaynerchuk who really is all
he's cracked up to be
I say that with no hesitation
extraordinary human being but Gary is
one of the first people I met with and I
pitched the product to him by myself as
best I could at the end of that pitch he
had this look on his face and I looked
and I said you don't have any idea what
this is do you and he's like I don't get
it at all and then he said put me down
for half a million and when I asked I
said why he said because I bet on I bet
on the jockey not on the horse and that
was extremely telling for me because I
think to hear Matt's story and what Matt
represents him why he's doing this and
then from me it is a much more
compelling story and much more
compelling narrative than what we saw
the potential of our products of our
product at the time and so were you
relying on each other during that sales
process because like I know like you're
for for people who don't know you like
you're a very very personable person and
not just like this engineer guy who sits
in the corner
like yeah it's I mean it's obvious
through the podcast but for those of you
who don't know because like what have
you learned from Casey in this whole
process
obviously your interesting person
YouTube does really well your
captivating and now you have a crazy
reach were you guiding this like
fundraising process or were you relying
on each other yeah I mean we're
absolutely relying on each other and I
think the thing about the fundraising
like fund raising acquisition process
both is we developed an act for both of
them or it was like the first time we
did it it was a disaster we were both
talking at the same point investor you
know sitting at Sequoia and Sequoia
Partners asks a question and we both
like look each other and start to answer
at the same time total disaster the pro
tips yeah so but no but it took I mean a
so the pro tip on fundraising actually
like those kind of sales processes like
start with someone you and don't this is
something someone gave us this advice
but like start with someone you don't
care about you don't think is gonna you
know you know them well enough to know
they're not gonna invest or like don't
don't shoot for the moon and then screw
it up but the first person you talk to
should be someone who you know is gonna
say now so you can get all the jitters
out you can try the act and literally
what we would do is you know we drove
all around the valley for our
fundraising and we would go to a meeting
you know have this very typical hour
meeting with a partner at a VC firm and
then we would go as far away as we could
so we would go to like a donut shop
where we knew nobody said that was gonna
be there was always there's this one in
Redwood City in fact that we probably
had I don't know 10 hours of
conversation in but we literally go to
this donut shop sit down and debug the
entire meeting we would just go there
and go like okay that part where you
jumped in and said X that was perfect we
need to do more of that or we got too
much in the weeds when they asked this
question like actually Casey you should
just take that one and kill it
immediately
so we developed a pretty honed routine
yeah and I'll say the
the SAP can bar was my MIT professor and
or one of the earliest investors the
first investor and winded up being beam
he said to me is like practice your
pitch on people that you don't want
money from don't practice on don't
practice on friends practice on real
world but real investors and when he
said this man I rolled my eyes not to be
dismissive of him but that idea just
seemed like why would I waste that
opportunity as just an exercise but he
could not have been more right he could
not have been more right if like you
know you have to your nerves your
anxiety all the things you think you're
going to say things that make sense in
your head when you get derailed by a
single question like all those things
are real world and they matter you know
I always think back to presidential
election or presidential debates and
like all the practicing they do like it
can prepare them in some capacity but
what the real world is like with those
cameras and all these variables so
fundraising for us exactly the same like
we learned so much more from when we
completely screwed up than we did from
the ones where people like I'm really
excited about this let lets you know we
could feel like it was a win those we
just walked away from high-fived and had
doughnuts with less conversation but
it's when we really [ __ ] up and there
were a couple like we should have been
home runs and I think that we just
screwed up and I just straight-up
did terrible pitches had a terrible time
specifically like what did you do poorly
in the pitch that people can learn from
sure okay well first of all your we're
going way back here this is I asked me
what my first date with my wife but I
think that failing to really understand
how siloed the skills that we uniquely
bring to the table are when I say steals
I don't just mean that the languages
that Matt can write code in I mean like
you know Casey should be this sort of
loud over-the-top
passionate blind aggressive sort of I
should be the hutzpah at the table
that's just like borderline hysterical
and matt has to be this like rock-solid
voice of reason that has an incredibly
practical like matt has to be the
confidence in case he has to be the
passion we didn't understand that and
the trouble with that is that's not a
square that
a passionate guy Matt someone who can be
like incredibly emotive and like we can
both represent that like I can sort of
[ __ ] about technicalities all day
long must instill confidence but like
he's better at that than I am and I'm
better at this than he is and like
understanding that and then to get more
granular it's like a question that may
seem like a technical question has an
answer that should be more driven by
passion than about the technicalities
how do you distinguish for that and then
like at what point in time do we stop
looking at each other to say who's going
to answer this one who let us know would
that poetry is going to be okay and that
Robert McNamara is sort of empathizing
with your enemies think it's like if I'm
being if I'm on the other side of the
table I want to see two people that are
firmly in control like I want to be
blinded with passion and then completely
reinforced the confidence that they know
how to turn that passion and just to a
real business and I think very difficult
for one person to represent that
dichotomy and that was something we
evolved into after a lot of screw-ups
well yeah I think the other like the
other thing this is derailing a little
bit but fundraising wise which I wish
somebody had told us and maybe they did
because we got so much advice which you
should get so much advice we talked to
SEP almost every day when we were in the
valley we would go back to the hotel
room and like Skype would say it was
incredible for doing that with us it's a
very busy man and but aside from getting
advice this is one that never either I
never heard and it didn't stick or or I
heard and it never stuck or I never
heard but understand what a know is and
understand the many many many varieties
of know that you can get from investors
and they're all knows and they all
should be treated the same so and this
is this is very smart on the uninvested
behalf they're very smart they want to
keep optionality they want to make it
possible to still invest in you if it
turns out to be a hot deal and they just
have the wrong perspective so you rarely
I think the best investors will give you
a strong now
but in general you'll rarely actually
get a know you'll get lots of things
that sound like yeses but are actually
knows some things like my favorite one
where Casey and I left the meeting and
we're like yes like that's a huge jack
excited our lead
and then we started talking to our
advisers and other investors and they're
like oh that's a no was is and this is
something that that I've since seen in
other companies have asked me for advice
is someone going that's great we're
totally in for X amount as soon as you
find a lead okay and that is just such
you're like alright great they're in for
X amount and actually they're not in at
all unless you can sell someone else
who's good willing to take more of the
risk but there's a million varieties of
that and there's some good blog posts
about this but just like understand that
if you don't have a term sheet it's not
a guess yeah and even if you have a term
sheet there's still some chance that
it's not a guess but probably is but
don't don't leave a meeting and here
yeah we're super interested tell me who
else is investing and you know we'll
definitely be in that's a know almost
everything other than a term sheet is it
no we we were raising in SEP was our
voice of reason he's just one of the
most thoughtful people especially when
it comes to fundraising or anything in
the startup world of anyone that I've
ever interacted with and he was he was
who we leaned on the most but we had
another friend who'll remain nameless
was in the valley at the time who was in
the process of it was like an 80 or 100
million dollar raise which he did
execute on and we would go meet with him
when we needed nothing more than a
proper ass-kicking and I remember when
we finally closed our lead which was a
wing in a prayer it was I think you know
the Jeremy Lou at Lightspeed really
believed in what we were doing he saw
the vision but I think the most
impressive thing about Jeremy is he took
a big swing he took a risk like he he I
can speak more to that but he he's an
incredible VC because of his willingness
to sort of assess and understand the
risk that he saw in us but he took that
chance and he was decisive too I think
lots of other investors he was like a
day later we got a yes extremely
decisive but when we went to this crazy
maniac that was our voice of insanity
and then I remember we finally told Mike
we got our lead we got our lead and I
just remember this guy being like okay
here's what you do
you get him on the phone and you say you
listen to me you [ __ ] bloodsucker
here's what we're gonna do
I want quadruple the amount of money a
10% evaluation that we discussed or the
deal's off the table and it was like I
think he was 80% serious when he was
talking like that and I think what I
learned from seeing that kind of like
maniac type person succeed exceed at
least in the fundraising part of the
process is that like just how much
people respond to that blind passion
because like he was he was he was nuts
but he was not for what he was doing so
much so that he's able to raise you know
nine figures based on his idea but Matt
I would always sort of leave our
meetings with him jazzed up and we would
always say like we would dismiss 99% of
what he said but that 1% was just enough
to sort of give us a little bit more
confidence in our and our in our future
pitches that's why it was there anything
you guys did to kind of build that up
within you because it's even just doing
like podcasting like the the counter
transference of energy between people is
such a thing that's not necessarily
obvious to people when they start
podcasting like what did you do to build
up that skill to countertransference I
was like power it's like this people's
use countertransference as a
psychological term of energy so if you
go into a room and you're kind of just
like it I understood what you meant I
just had never heard that yeah okay
what did you ask me how do we do I get
better at it how do you get better at it
yeah I want I think Matt is like an
extremely level person and I'm I'm not
and seeing I know I mean it and like if
Matt gets nervous I've never seen him
show it and I have to say like I drew a
lot from that like there was a lot I
think walking into a meeting alone would
have been very very scary but like that
countertransference was not was not from
them to me but it was sort of mitigated
by the fact that there's you know two
people on this side of the table and
again that sort of dovetails back into
that balancing act that that I've been
Costello routine that we had worked
ourselves into but for me that's what a
lot of it was was
like learning how to rely on that to
keep myself level in meetings and be as
effective as possible mmm
I think the other thing is just getting
yourself in the mindset like before
especially if you go to like Sand Hill
Road if you go to these places that feel
that are designed to feel powerful is to
just take a breath outside and go I got
invited here like I got this meeting I
think that was easier for me to do
because I've been part of tumblers
fundraises and have been to a lot of
like big to this physical spaces it was
like it's okay
but even if you haven't I think it's
just important to sit there and go like
this isn't you know I'm not begging I'm
looking for a partner I came here
because you invited me mmm just to get
yourself in that mindset of look
absolutely belong in this room what's
what's a little bit more
counterintuitive advice that you've
learned along the way I know Matt you
think a lot about startups maybe Casey
similarly think about startups all the
time but also just creative work what's
the counter intuitive advice you've
learned sure I mean my my
counterintuitive advice is just the
power of brute force and I mean that I
think that it's always about
intellectualizing and thoughtfulness and
listening to more podcast and reading
more books and all that I think at the
end of the day like it is it is brute
force it is hard work it is an absolute
unwillingness to to accept failure to
accept know and that's true with
fundraising and that's true with
ideation and that's true with making a
youtube video and you know in the home
of my 36 and the 18 years of my career I
found that to be the one sort of
consistent the one constant through
everything that in any in any version of
success it's been because of an absolute
reluctance and of that sort of brute
force I will not stop moving until I
achieve what I wanted to succeed and
what I want to achieve and every time
where that I would identify as a failure
it was because of a lack of that or
questioning of that and I think beam 1.0
is a very good example like our product
failed that the company succeeded and I
think a lot of that comes back to sort
of that absolute relent is the
relentlessness and tenacity
not just Matt and I as leaders but the
entire team we had a product that was
family like no nobody other team quit
nobody cared nobody really gave a [ __ ]
his heads down what else can we build so
we started building all these weird
products and experimenting and we built
one about the election and it was just
like no let's just keep going heads down
keep moving keep pushing keep pushing
and I think that that is not sexy advice
that's not romantic advice that's not
something that can be analyzed and
broken down but I do think it's
absolutely pivotal for for any kind of
success in life is to embody that and
everything you do mine's not necessarily
counterintuitive but I think especially
for engineers people with a more
technical mindset it's really tough to
learn is just ask for what you want
super directly I mean sit in the really
like this is a very tactical sort of
micro thing but I think it's something
that I see I'm now on the receiving end
of a lot because people are asking me
for start-up advice and I often get
emails that are just super roundabout in
it essentially hey can I I'm starting a
company it's a social app can I get by
you coffee
I don't wanna be bought coffee if you
sent me a one-line email that said hey
I'm really looking for an amazing iOS
engineer who's looking to found a
company like about there are three
people I can introduce you to and I can
I can do the research on who you are you
don't need to fill me and I'd like just
ask if that's what you're asking
I'd love to help if if you're asking for
an hour of my time to vaguely talk about
ideas I don't know
I literally have the words pick your
brain I had that as a Gmail filter so if
somebody emails me saying I'd love to
buy you lunch so I can pick your their
filter and they go me in the trash yeah
I'm completely like how I start me I had
literally was running last week and a
woman stopped me and she works at a big
one of the biggest publishers in the
city and she's I don't want to have
lunch through and discuss with you this
thing I'm building I think you could be
a really big part of it and looked at it
and I was like what is it and what are
the actionable x' and she's like well
let's sit down let's have it and I was
like I have three minutes right now tell
me what it is and tell me what you want
from me and she could not do that she
couldn't do it there's no [ __ ] way
I'm giving this
an hour of my time well and if you can't
do that you're probably not ready that's
it get that advice to ask that question
like if you can't write it in the
subject of the email and this is my
favorite by the way like my team
probably gets annoyed at some point
probably some 10 of these emails today
but it's just a question that it's the
long subject line of the email and that
is it
yeah and that is me asking for something
very directly that I need if you're not
in a place where you can do that and it
might be hey I think you might like I
need really specific advice about how to
build a technical team can you give me
advice on how to how to build a
technical team for my company of eight
like that's that's a specific question I
can do something with respecting other
people's time is something that sounds
sillier elementary but like especially
in the in the world of startups like
nobody has time so respecting other
people's I think is absolutely paramount
and and I think that comes down to how
effective of a communicator you are and
I think that that idea permeates
everything we've discussed today from
fundraising to being an effective
manager to being a good leader to being
good at anything but if you can't be
effective in the way you communicate and
not waste other people's time I think
it's it's difficult to succeed in this
space so Matt one of the questions we
got like over and over and over again
was about the acquisition so we talked
about this off-camera but if someone
asks you how do how do I get acquired
what do you say the number one place
where I would start with this is it
takes forever and people will tell you
this our best advisors told us this they
said it takes six months if you want to
go down that path at a minimum and me is
a like process optimizer hyper-organized
like now we can of course we can in
three months you cannot so 90% of people
ask me this question
when they've got a month of cash left
and the answer is you can't there's no
like what's that thing we were told so
many times it's like you can never you
can never sell your startup it can only
be bought yes something like that
because we were trying to raise more
like I think the best move here is for
us to to sell this time like let's be a
part of something bigger than us I think
it's how we can be most effective and
most successful and like the first move
the minute we started telling our
trusted advisors either they will stop
saying that
don't ever say that what you're doing
right now is your fundraising and when
you meet with people who you think might
be interested in buying your company you
tell them you're fundraising you were
never in the process of selling your
company until it's been sold and that is
extremely good advice because throughout
the entire process just how true and we
spoke with a number of potential
acquirers like it was a it was a major
process for us and that one truth sort
of permeated every single conversation I
don't know we're not selling the company
we're interested in something I've never
actually we're going to love a raise
right now which was 100% true but it
didn't sort of it was you'd say oh that
revealing your whole card which is that
you know were very interested in
pursuing potential acquisition
opportunities and how did you manage so
CN n like slides an offer across the
table and what do you do after the fact
or maybe that's not even how it works
were that it were that simple
no I mean to talk about how we even get
to how you get to that first offer that
probably you know we made we made the
decision sometime in the spring say
March or April were like we're going out
for this race but we should really
really seriously talk to go Pyrus and
like let's put our energy and focus
actually there that decision led to
probably four months of conversations
with eight to ten different companies
none of which because because of the
psychology of it were you really that
Casey said that devices is very true you
can't go in and say hey we're selling
the company and so those conversations
had to be pretty roundabout they had to
be well we're doing a raise and we think
it might be interesting to have you
strategically involved oh we're looking
for deeper partnership all these sort of
by words were people ISM no we're saying
but it just it took an enormous amount
of time because you can't you couldn't
be that direct you know the irony of all
this I don't know if you know this Matt
but like my first meeting ever with Jeff
Zucker was not about beam it was about
YouTube and meeting with his his son was
on his way to Harvard and it was a bit
was a broader conversation but at the
very end of that meeting when Jeff who
just had knee surgery was rushing out to
another meeting and running a gigantic
company and had two kids in the room as
I was leaving that meeting with my
skateboard in a hand Jeff said how can
we work together and I looked at him and
I said you should buy my technology
company so there was no beating around
the bush there was no bullshitting and
that was for a lot of reasons it was
because of someone like that who is as
you know III think his capable and as
smart as a Jeff Zucker like I had I had
30 seconds for I was walking out the
door there was no bullshitting someone
like that in that position so knowing
when to sort of lay all your cards on
the table and say this is what's in
front of me I think it's also like that
is just pure sort of human nature like
understanding what might feel
appropriate about that I also think it
was a the fact that it was a media
company that Jeff stock was at the helm
of not a technology company you know
they're not used to typical tech
acquisitions the way that a gigantic
tech company might be so it there was
some latitude there for some creativity
and how we kind of pitched it and I will
say immediately thereafter I immediately
after that conversation it did become
much more typical the next step was that
meeting with Matt and understanding
technically what we had and I'm sending
a team down here to sort of interview
our team to see if we're as capable as
we say we are looking at some of the
tech we've built like digging into it
like it was a very very formal process
that was initiated by a very office Huff
statement I think the other key thing
there is that we were far enough along
in conversations with a couple of other
companies that's right we could really
we could leverage that right it's say
look with that [ __ ] and you can't
[ __ ] because you're yeah if you're
in the valley all everyone talks to each
other assume that all the information is
out there if you're not in the valley
it's maybe tuned down a little bit but
still like don't get caught lying it's
not it's not worth it it doesn't make
sense right but you could stretch you
can push you can and we legitimately
were in other conversations and so we
could say listen we're in other
conversations that are moving along and
constantly create these forcing factors
we need to tell we need to tell this
technology company that shall remain
unnamed whether whether we should pursue
the process or not we need to hear from
you by Friday and we could only say that
and we did say literally what Matt just
said we said do we use those exact words
those are the semantics we used but we
could say that
we can say it with confidence because we
weren't bullshitting and I think if
there was no truth to saying something
like that then that would have been
found out that would have that would
have been transparent no matter how
convincing either of us could have been
and is this all wisdom from your
advisers because it's unlike meeting
with investors you can't really do that
there's not a lot of like dry runs of
these acquisition conversations we I
mean one so they're two of our investors
advisors who were super instrumental in
this episode super instrument as well
yeah I'm the one said I'm thinking for
brunei ryan's berg and merrick last name
I can't pronounce that's terrible of
locu and they had gone through this
process with GoDaddy maybe a year before
we had and so they they just like Renee
was so tuned to exactly the moments we
were in and we did the same thing the
fundraising room would be like we would
debrief at least once a week if not two
or three times a week with him and just
go here's they said here's what they
said those were those were yeah those
throughout the acquisition process they
were much closer to therapy like you go
to a therapist because you need to make
sense of all the things in your brain
and like we would go to Renee to make
sense of all the things existing in our
our acquisition conversations because it
was it was very hard to find anything
sort of sensible or straight line in
there for us to build actionable around
but a difficult scary process that I
think was made easier by the fact that
our backs were up against the wall like
Matt and I knew we knew when we were out
of money we knew when when the gig was
up and there was something for me
something very confidence-inspiring
about that it was black and white it
wasn't that didn't make me more scared
it was like optionality I think can
often be to one's detriment I would say
that like when people ask me what was it
like having a kid when you were 17
versus having a kid now
and it was like well I have resources
now have money now and I have 17 as I'm
welfare so it's very easy when I had oh
and this is a binary can I have that no
yeah can I do this no yeah and now as I
have this little kid and like I just
want to give her whatever the hell she
wants and she's like a spoiled monster
who waits at that point the more
efficient wants to play with Elsa
but yet there was something about the
do-or-die environment with which we were
going through the acquisition process
that I found tremendous confidence in
and was this um were there any books you
resorted to throughout this process to
kind of like figure out you know like a
mental model or like how to deal with
this or is it just straight-up advisors
advisor therapy I mean there are it's
funny I ended up buying like it's like
venture deals for entrepreneur like
venture and acquisitions for
entrepreneurs like a literal like
business school textbook which was
useful for looking up like three terms
in the and the eventual term sheets we
got but no advice I read all I read all
those books because of my own
insecurities and I went through you know
every VC that I was a fan of all their
blogs all the way back and all of that
helped to the same degree that like I
did give you a book on how to read on
how to skateboard and you can study that
book and memorize that book and fall off
the board immediately but skate with
Tony Hawk for five minutes and you'll be
better than anything that book could
impart and I think that's what it was
like for our advisors is one 30-minute
conversation with Renee or would SAP
informed us in such a tremendously
impactful way that everything that had
read up and told them just sort of felt
like yeah it was it was it felt
unnecessary because it was in real world
it wasn't reacting to our specific set
of circumstances so how could I apply
these general these general principles
to what is a very very nuanced
environment I also think people the
psychology of it is just so hard like
this is the part that nobody told nobody
told us about because it's not really a
way to talk about it huh but the
psychology especially with your team is
one of the hardest parts because you are
you know feels like you're cheating when
you're because you've not told your team
you're potentially selling the company
and I'm gonna disappear San Francisco
for three days under the guise where I
made money I'm just gone for a couple
days under the guise so I mean the way
that we did it is we told in Crete we
told everyone increasingly more as the
certainty went up
my feeling about all this and just this
is a general thing being a man your
manager executive founder is you should
get people as much information as
possible you really should try and be
transparent if that information is
actionable if it can actually cause them
to do something
create a new venture build a new tool
build something that will actually have
an impact on it there is zero you can do
as an engineer on our team if I say
we're talking to CNN and these six other
companies about potentially being
acquired all that does is make you panic
and go okay paralysis and this is it
this is a team of a dozen people who
rely on their paychecks as everybody
else does who's aware of the fact that
our core product is not working we've
stopped really focusing on it they don't
know what else we're focused on they
don't know what the future of this
company is and they're unbelievably
talented and skilled and sought-after by
other companies so how you know you
can't [ __ ] them and you can't tell
them the process like what Matt just
described so you don't have anything to
tell them so it's just really like avoid
eye-contact scary
and this isn't days this is months I was
like the more I think one of the best
one of the best business decisions Matt
and I ever made was was summer 2016
we're out of money
we had like five months left of money we
could barely pay like our amazon bills
like we were struggling we're pinching I
it didn't work I had cut my salary to
zero we were struggling we didn't know
what to do
we were just started we didn't know what
to do so we Matt and I came up with this
decision like it was one of our meetings
it's like okay nothing's off the table
what should we do right now and we came
up with the decision to spend God knows
how much money renting to huge mansions
on the beach and the Dominican Republic
and flying the entire team flying the
entire team down there for a vacation at
the beach where we all like rented
banana boats and when fishing and Matt
crashed a golf car and I think at the
time it was just like we needed to do it
because we needed to we needed to talk
we needed
to fix things we need to show a vote of
confidence in the team but what that
enables us to do is get the hell out of
the office break that unwillingness to
make eye contact to be as honest with
the team about how we can't be honest
with the team you know there was a
common there were many conversations I
was like look guys we want to share with
you what's going on but like it's a
liability we can't like read between the
lines we're trying to figure things out
all we're asking for you is you know
have confidence in us I think the other
thing that you have to have if you're
trying to manage your own psychology in
the situation is you have to think it's
it all goes south everything goes to
[ __ ] deal falls through I'm gonna spend
every waking hour making sure that
everyone on my team Lance with an
amazing job I'm gonna pump my network
I'm gonna make sure that everyone gets
out of this before I think about myself
and that was always something roll in
the back of my mind was like all right
what doesn't come through and run out of
cash like well that's what I'm gonna do
okay and having that that at least
helped me get going okay like I can
actually help everyone land in a great
place and frankly because everyone is an
engineer highly sought-after like
they're gonna be okay
let's like as long as I know I'm gonna
dedicate myself to that if it doesn't
work out then it's okay yeah we did I
think through all the tumult that was
the last quarter of being 1.0
pre-acquisition you know no one on our
team ever there was never a miss payroll
there was never a delayed payroll like
this was something that Matt and I have
always made priority number one and I
think that like look no one left no one
left and this is a shitty seven-month
process really from when we knew this
app was not going to succeed what's next
and then telling them that we're gonna
be acquired it was it was not a short
amount of time and little things like
that stupid retreat the Dominican
Republic was just sort of it was us
showing it was us trying to demonstrate
the team how much we believe in them
like guys look here's something awesome
we're gonna do together does it make
sense right now from afar probably not
but like we're all here having
conversations we wouldn't be having at
1:00 in the morning
we're drinking like really terrible warm
beer and the effectiveness and the
importance of that like these are things
that are intangible things that are that
are very challenging to quantify
chemistry is something that you cannot
quantify but I think it is chemistry
that
makes a team both on the inside and on a
media side on the creative side it makes
a team cohesive it's what makes a team
work it's what makes a team ultimately
effective and it's easier to do when
you're small and as you grow it gets
more and more challenging but that was
always a really really primary focus for
us through all the ups and downs of us
being a venture-backed startup would you
change anything about how you did it I
mean me personally yeah I you know I
never ever talked to anyone on the team
about the vlog and I the reason why is
because I knew in the back of my head
how instrumental the vlog could be to
benefit this company and I had
insecurities about saying that the
team's I didn't want it to diminish
their work and then ultimately if we
didn't succeed you know I wouldn't have
wanted to falsify expectations because
of the success of this YouTube channel
yeah so inside just kept my mouth shut
and made videos all day every day and I
think that that must have been really
challenging for the team to see but then
in the end like you know it was a big
part of why the acquisition took place
it's why now this is not just that no
longer just a technology company but a
media and technology company is because
I think there was a demonstration of
what we can do within that cross-section
so I guess the the question that I've
been wondering is this whole process of
like you guys getting together starting
beam selling beam working at CNN
tremendous learning experience and it
probably seems like a crazy amount of
time but it's been like what 2 years 3
years it's been 3 a little over 3 years
okay so what are you what are you
working to learn now like how are you
personally trying to improve yourselves
I mean for me this is about learning to
run a completely different kind of
company and a completely different scale
company to think about a business that
I've never had to think of which is
media like we were a technology and
media company technology I think I
understand the parameters their media I
don't and I'm learning on the job and
that's like that is 95% of my what I'm
reading what I'm consuming who I'm
sure that I had breakfast lunch and
dinner with is learning that yeah I've
never had a job before the last time I
get a paycheck every two weeks the last
time I got a paycheck over to East when
I was washing dishes and I was 16 years
old in southeastern Connecticut I mean
I've never had a job before yeah it's
not sort of a fun new thing for me to
learn about but certainly like working
with teams and you know I've always been
an entrepreneur I've started and built
companies my entire life since I you
know stoves in my early 20s and
understanding that our focus here is
purely on building a successful company
not so much worrying about kind of the
resources that are around us like I look
at these cameras and I immediately what
I mean by that is I look at these
cameras I immediately get stressed out
so I know how much that cost I have to
figure out how much we're gonna earn to
be able to compensate for that the price
of that camera and then understanding
that when you're part of in the
apparatus when you're part of something
that is is huge as Time Warner as CNN
that those sort of considerations are
not entirely relevant because there this
is a long game this is a long play for
CNN like they want being to be wildly
successful for the next 10 20 years they
want to break into new markets and
that's how they view it and that is so
foreign to me
I mean beam 1.0 venture back Matt and I
were week to week focused on the success
of that cut I'm getting really upset
when I found out people were ordering
blue bottles in the carton or whatever
the hell it was cuz there are six bucks
each and be like we can't afford this
right now this is absurd so being an
environment like this where it's it's
not about sort of the minute by minute
or the day by day but really trying to
build a successful company that will
last long into the future it's
completely foreign to me because as a
start-up as a startup entrepreneur it's
always like it's always that day-to-day
it's always about the right now and
we're trying to build something that has
much much longer legs and so that's just
done by what stepping back and like kind
of imagining what your more absolutely
like deep breaths kind of thing it's
like you know we talk about the reason
why I don't take it granular like an
example we had discussed yesterday with
the teams it's like I'm not promoting
beams to youtube channel on my main
YouTube channel right now and the reason
why is I want the dent the bench to be
deeper on memes channel we have like
nine videos
right now I wanted to be 20 amazing
videos so when I push my audience there
which haven't done in a while and they
show up they're like whoa this is
incredible and it's like yeah I want to
do it today so I want to see our numbers
bump today but let's be thoughtful here
let's understand what the long play is
here and like if my if I'm going to ask
that of my audience I want them to be
really rewarded by what they find when
they get here and we're not there yet so
it's like taking that deep breath taking
a step back from those no no let's be
thoughtful here and doing that at every
turn is a foreign practice for me one of
the fun things about getting into the
media side of things has been learning
how expensive that media especially does
not have processed thinking in the way
that engineering does yeah and I and I
think that a typical engineer would be
shocked to see that there are all of the
elements of an agile or similar sort of
methodology of development but none of
the vocabulary and none of the sort of
feedback loops which are actually
critical to making that happen and this
is not I don't like a file naming
convention but I think if you ask people
on our media team like and I have people
on our team or like this is the most
transparent feedback oriented media team
I've ever been on and I look at it I'm
like oh my god this is so much messier
and way way less feedback like they
don't there's not a two-week sprint
there's not a retrospective and so I
think as an engineering manager I'm
starting to realize how much of that is
applicable to media and I'm also
learning where it is absolutely not
applicable hmm but it's been so long I
think it's of interest to listen to the
podcast is engineering thinking has
applications way outside running an
engineering team and I think I have some
unique advantages and some disadvantages
in running a media team because of that
I think that everything Matt just said
really underscores why I I find such
success in - ease in making content when
it's just me and why I struggle so much
when it's a team because everything that
he just described is exactly right when
you talk about inefficiencies and
opportunities for greater efficiency but
where does efficiency contradict
creativity what are those - butt heads
and if you're focused on efficiency
there's creativity start to fade and
all of those variables are completely
annihilated when it's a one-man show
right because none of those
considerations have to take place there
is none of that intellectualization
taking place it's purely that brute
force start at zero get across the
finish line and that's an environment I
[ __ ] love and thrive in in an
environment that's far more managed is
one that then I'm like that's the thing
I'm most excited about really learning
are you guys doing any like long long
term planning for your lives like do you
have a long-term goal like Casey or Matt
20 years from now yeah I mean I have a
half of one day three day five day one
week one month three months six months
I'm not kidding one year all right
what's it how far out can you go and I'm
all the way to death all right like I
have hired a man or you die I mean
really like you want to be into that I
was curious like how you guys are
thinking about the future sure what
you're working at - I mean from a more
granular perspective it's like I I want
to move to Los Angeles on leave and you
leave New York City in the next three to
five years and I want to do that because
like you know I think New York City is a
wonderful place from 20 to 40 but 40 to
60 I want to be out of New York City I
think New York's amazing when you're
young and broke or old and rich and I'm
neither of those so in raise our kids
outside of the city so when I think
about that what the implications could
be you know even bringing that idea up -
Matt very anecdotally he's like well
look if we don't if beam doesn't have an
office in LA in three to five years we
got bigger problems and like I love
hearing that so it's like that's that's
nothing more than a little sort of
nugget that's a tiny nail for me to
start hanging things off of but this is
the kind of planning that eventually
like those ideas turn into actionable
those actionable is become much more
practical and three to five years from
now who knows but some version of what's
now consideration will most likely be
the reality that's some broad strokes
that's a five-year plan okay
for me it's critical to have a totally
different career like I want to I don't
know when this is then I have thoughts
and timing and
yeah I've already I guess you could say
I'm probably on my second or third
career but I have a degree of Victorian
Studies
I knew this but the listeners did I also
I also my first career which lasted at
approximately 18 months was in
contemporary art but no I think the
biggest sort of long-term goal in my
head is find success in a completely
different career completely different
field start from scratch
learn something completely different I
have a few thoughts on what what the
possibilities for that are but I just
think you know I I want to basically be
at the bottom again and learn how to do
something completely different that's
great
all right let's wrap it up thanks guys
yeah of course
you